ladies and gentlemen welcome back Rachel
Kleinfeld modern wisdom how are you
today very well going to be here Chris
I'm really excited to speak to you today
it's a turbulent time in politics and
the the 21st century for governments
trying to make themselves work
effectively so I think it's gonna be a
really interesting conversation I'm
reading your bio here a senior fellow of
the Carnegie Endowment for international
peace and the founding CEO of the Truman
National Security Project is that right
mm-hmm those sounds like situations
where there's lots of serious stuff
happening all the time well there's
certainly a lot of attempts to have
serious conversations about serious
issues yes but you know the world of
think tanks in Washington DC is is one
of it by advising so if I die government
advisor government in Britain and all
around the world trying to try to make a
difference yeah something tells me that
you don't get much time to just like
crack jokes and kind of chill out it's
probably a lot of serious stuff we have
our fun but you know I'm not I'm not
present there very often I spend an
awful lot of time at 40,000 feet so you
know flying from place to place tit so
my phone is generally on the fly in
different countries doing you know
eating Street food in Afghanistan or or
riding lorries and Bangladesh that kind
of thing that's pretty cool so we're
going to talk about a savage order which
is your new book can you tell us why you
started writing this and and what did
you want to find out when you began
absolutely so when you work in a
think-tank there's a lot of serious talk
because you've discussed but there can
also be a lot of talk that doesn't
really go anywhere and so I wanted to
see could we do anything about the
problem of violence I spent all my time
reading about it thinking about it how
do we end conflicts what do we do about
violence and it turned out we knew very
little about what actually worked and so
I pulled together a big conference I
brought together
the experts on electoral violence on
organized crime on gang violence you
have it we had them all in a room
together if a bomb had gone off in that
room brain power ended and I said you
know what do we know and we put together
a literature review on here's all that
we knew which was quite a lot we had a
great deal of knowledge actually about
how you fight gangs how you get better
policing all sorts of things and then I
said okay well how would you get a
corrupt police force in X country to
adopt these ideas and you know the room
just went silent and I thought okay
that's the problem I need to focus on
for this book Wow so you must have had
to include certain areas and exclude
other ones with a certain geographic
locations that you focused on yeah so
when I first wrote the book I thought it
would be a pretty typical think-tank
book of lots of little ideas that you
know lots of little different kinds of
violence and different ways to fight it
and so I picked case studies on every
continent on earth that was settled so
not Antarctica but everywhere else if
this was going on in Antarctica and
gangs roving gangs of emperor penguins
[Laughter]
so you know we went to Italy and we
looked at why the mob ended in Sicily or
prettier was really decimated in Sicily
and and was so very present in Naples
and was spreading in the rest of Italy
we looked at the Republic of Georgia
which was an ex-soviet state broke away
why had it gotten so much better when
Tajikistan had fallen into a kind of an
authoritarian dictatorship Nigeria
versus Ghana Mexico versus Columbia why
did Columbia and its civil war and
really fight its violence while Mexico
is just getting worse and worse in terms
of violence they're Bihar India versus
Johar Khan and that was one state had a
lot of Maoist violence and criminal
violence and insurgency and right below
it the state that had been the break
away the two had been one state and
they'd been separated by the federal
government the other one couldn't fight
in one part and then my sort of fun case
you asked about whether we have fun and
things thanks
my fun case was looking at the u.s. the
u.s. south after the Civil War versus
the Wild West and why did the Wild West
actually get better pretty quickly it
went from wild not particularly wild in
about 30 years whereas the u.s. south is
still the most violent part of America
and certainly was back then and after
the Civil War became more and more
violent over time and so that was
probably the key to the whole book
actually was that that case that's
interesting so did you find any common
principles amongst all of these areas
obviously they'll have been
characteristics that were particular to
within them I suppose
what were the overarching narratives
that you came up with yeah so as I said
I thought I was going to write lots of
little things and what does the mob have
to do with the post-civil war America in
the West but what I found as I went from
place to place was these themes kept
recurring I kept seeing the same ideas
the same thoughts and I was trying to
figure it out when you do a book like
this you travel all over you're really
jet-lagged you're talking to everyone
you can get your hands on so you might
do 80-100 interviews in a country you're
reading everything and my husband
laughed at me because he said you know
for five years you never read a book
that wasn't about violence and worry
about you know so I'm just you're taking
all this information that you're trying
to make sense of it and as I was trying
to make sense that I was doing my fun
case about American history and that was
the key because the Wild West was a very
violent weak state and when we think
about states in my profession that are
very violent and it are democracies and
I should say I only looked at
democracies because I wanted to know how
they got better and autocracies have a
very different way of getting bad and
getting better it's just a different
kind of a situation so when you look at
a very violent democracy people tend to
assume that they're weak States after
all if you can't protect your voters you
must be too weak to protect your voters
because your voters must be asking for
protection it disgust to reason but the
US West was that so I tell the story in
the book of Theodore Roosevelt who was a
president of ours a hundred years ago
but he was also a cattle rancher before
he was the president South Dakota and
someone stole his boat and he needed to
get his boat back and so he got together
a posse in a typical Wild West fashion
and they went down the river to get the
criminals and
after three days on the river they found
the bad guys they arrested them they put
handcuffs on them or whatever they had
back then you know tied them up onto
their raft and then it froze the river
froze and so for two weeks they were
stuck on frozen river with three
criminals that they had to feed that to
keep everybody alive that floored this
frozen river they finally hit land the
posse leaves they have jobs they need to
go back to their ranches Theodore
Roosevelt was independently wealthy so
he takes his criminals and he walks for
36 hours he walks with them to the
nearest jail and you can imagine that
not being a particularly fun experience
and when he got to the the town that had
the jail someone there said well why
didn't you just shoot them and that made
a lot of sense actually because in that
kind of a circumstance you can't sleep
for 36 hours because it's you against
three criminals you can't you know just
the sheer logistics of bringing someone
to justice in a weak state that has poor
capacity is a mess and so you get a lot
of violence that is people trying to
solve these problems for themselves and
you see that in a lot of weak states
today and that's the theory when we go
to help Afghanistan or we go to help
Nigeria we say oh they're too weak let's
bulk up their security services let's
train them and how to shoot let's train
them in logistics and so on and help
them fight people that they clearly want
to fight but that was not the issue in
the u.s. south and so that was the key
because in the US South you had courts
you had judges you had police you had
all the things you need for a state it
wasn't a weak state at all what it was
was a complicit state and so in the u.s.
south after the Civil War the old
Confederate leadership wanted to have be
back in power but they couldn't be
because blacks had been in franchised
and so they weren't going to vote for
their former slave owners and so on and
most Confederates had been
disenfranchised so what do they do well
at the same time you had the Ku Klux
Klan start up and you had a bunch of
groups Nightrider groups as they were
called these white supremacist groups
all over the south they didn't start
because the politicians made them start
they started because they were racist
horrible people but the politicians
a confluence of interest what the
politician saw was that if you harassed
and terrified African Americans you
would also be terrifying the voting base
for the other party because they were
going to vote for the other party and so
if you chased enough of them out of town
if you killed enough of them
if you scared enough of them they
wouldn't vote and so that's what
happened and so you saw pogroms and
lynchings and so on
spike right before elections and you saw
people get away scot-free because the
deal that the Confederates made an
implicit deal but fairly explicitly
implicit the Ku Klux Klan had their big
annual meeting the same weekend at the
same hotel in Tennessee as the
Democratic Party of Tennessee see it
just happened but you saw a lot of
parties back then right violence into
their electoral plans you know there get
out the vote plans have these parts in
them that talked about electoral
violence and using that as part of their
strategy and the caucus at the time yes
really people don't know this part of
the US history we don't talk about
reconstruction it's it's it's a rough
period bill burns is actually just about
to do a documentary on it so then
hopefully people will know more about it
but the US Congress avoided more than
two dozen elections because of the level
of violence and sent people back and you
know had you had to do recounts that was
so bad but as Confederates got back into
power through these violent means as
they suppress the vote of the other side
and got back into power they of course
turned back the clock on federal
legislation that would fight that kind
of violence they made it harder to do
and the Supreme Court was quite
conservative and it worked with them and
said no no murder is a state issue
federal law doesn't cover murder so you
can't try people there was a Ku Klux
Klan act that was a law to make a murder
a federal crime because they knew that
the southern courts weren't prosecuting
it and the you know they turns that back
so gradually within about a decade
decade and a half the old Confederates
who had lost the Civil War won the peace
and they were back the power and the
deal they had made with these
violent groups was ok you can commit
your violence we're not going to help
you we're not going to give you arms
we're not going to give you money but
we're going to give you impunity you're
going to be allowed to do it as much as
you want and you're not going to go to
jail it's going to be impossible to
convict a white person for killing a
black person or raping or you know
that's what I saw in country after
country with were these implicit deals
that are being made with states that
aren't week.but have deliberately chosen
to allow a certain amount of violence by
other act by non-state actors as we say
in the business by groups that are not
part of the state for their own reasons
sometimes it's bribery you know
sometimes it's electoral violence like
in the South they want it so press the
other boat sometimes they want money so
in Colombia a third of the Colombian
Parliament was being had their campaigns
paid for by paramilitary groups the
paramilitary groups were deeply tied to
the drug cartels so you know who's not
going to get prosecuted you see that
same kind of thing you also see just
personal enrichment you know some
particularly der you're seeing that in
Central America right now where Jimmy
Morales and Guatemala just kicked out
the UN Council that was looking into
corruption as soon as they started
moving from organized crime corruption
to campaign finance corruption suddenly
they got kicked out of the country you
allowed to do that you're allowed to
just get rid of the UN in that
particular case yes because they've been
invited in and the UN has to work with a
member state mandate so the Attorney
General that's basically the law
enforcement has invited them in and said
hey we want the UN to clean up our
business here and the executive who had
been elected on an anti-corruption
platform but clearly with some
problematic background to that would let
them do what they wanted to do to a
certain point but not to [ __ ] within
the confines so there's a couple of
things that have come up first off is
the campaign violence that you mentioned
to me sounds exactly the same as the
rule that you guys have an ice-hockey
where you're allowed to punch each other
in the face until one person falls on
the floor like it just seems like a
completely bizarre rule that's kind of
loosely associated with the actual game
butch totally should not be allowed like
you shouldn't be allowed to punch
another sportsman in the face
in the same way as you should be allowed
to use tactics which encourage people to
swayed people towards your particular
point of view but not punching them in
the face like supposed to work your
violence is supposed to be issued by all
sides yeah but it's so easy right if you
can get away with it in these states and
you don't think you can win legitimately
why not go back you have to be a pretty
good and so so you see this being used
over and over and over again in these
countries because they have impunity
they can do it yeah I get that the other
thing so you mentioned right the very
start of that little segment you
mentioned about countries that have weak
democracies or people that generally
think about weak what do you think that
the general public at large or
potentially even your colleagues as well
what do you think that they think of
when they think of a weak democracy what
do you think that word brings up sure so
I mean a particular thing I mean a
democracy that that is highly highly
polarized and highly unequal that's
where you see this happen highly
polarized highly unequal so the people
are at each other's throats and won't
necessarily believe facts about the
other party so you see in Italy for
instance the Christian Democratic Party
was pretty tied together with the Mafia
for many many decades they were using
them for get out the vote the mafia
would then get contracts the Mafia would
be able to hire more people for
construction and what-have-you those
were more people to get out the vote and
it was kind of a tiny little system the
Communist Party kept saying this they
kept saying hey look the Christian
Democratic Party was working with the
Mafia and the Christian Democrats would
say that's just the Communists talking
do you want to believe the Communists
besides they're tied in with the Soviet
Internationale and that was also true
the Communist Party of Italy was deeply
deeply paid for by the Soviet Union and
so they could they could dissuade people
from looking into the Mafia contacts by
undermining the credibility of the
Communists so you see that kind of
polarization making it impossible to
solve the problem and you see high high
levels of the inequality and
inequality matters because it makes it
really hard for the middle class to
imagine what's going on in other
people's lives when these democracies
become violent the middle class doesn't
tend to face the violence they tend to
look different you know Guatemala for
instance there are lighter skinned
they're taller they can be a head taller
than an indigenous person they live in
different neighborhoods and so the
violence is happening to poor people or
marginalized people people who look
different and when it happens you read
it in the newspaper maybe maybe it
doesn't even make the paper because it's
so normal for people to be harmed in
those parts of town and you say oh well
they're in the bad part of town it's
just criminals killing criminals that's
what happens in those part and so you
see a lot of rationalization on the part
of the middle class where they say it's
over there it's not touching me I can
ignore it and besides they're probably
involved in the business is it's usually
in Mexico for instance even though
20,000 people are dying a year they say
oh it's probably just people involved in
the business it's not regular people
like me and so I can as distance myself
yeah yeah I mean that I'm gonna guess as
well that the middle class will be a
heavy bulk of the voters as well and
probably the ones who would be the ones
that will swing also and make big
differences in elections that's exactly
right because the the poor and
marginalized they just don't vote as
much maybe they're being maybe they're
facing election violence that's keeping
them from voting
maybe exactly exactly who's gonna play
ice hockey following apparently
Americans do I don't follow but a lot of
people won't play ice hockey if those
are the rules right you're not gonna
vote with that but it might also be that
there's just nothing on offer right if
it's an oligarchy system it's a
democracy but basically it's the same
elites who run the show whether it's
right or left whoever you vote for
nothing's gonna change for you might
take the time to bother voting and so
you see a lot of people choosing not to
vote because they don't see an option
even if the violence isn't specifically
targeting them so you're right the
middle class are the voters and if they
can pretend the violence won't hit them
it can go on for a really long time and
get pretty darn bad I get that so other
than the issues of personal safety and
personal privacy and then the
I guess the manipulation of particular
parties getting into power within these
countries is there a wider problem than
this is there downstream is there
something that happens that you can see
if these in inequalities and these weak
weak democracies continue to roll
forward is there a 2.0 version of this
which is a bigger nastier beast that we
really need to be worried about I was I
was really really hoping you're going to
say no I wish I could say no I wish I
could say no the book I should say is
positive the book is about how you get
out of this system so we can talk about
how you get into it but I'd love to talk
some about how you get out of it because
that was what interested me but yes it
does get nastier because what basically
happens is you have a group of
politicians who think we can't win a
legitimate clean election we're not
going to get in power we want campaign
finance money from organized criminals
we want to enable violence that's
electoral violence we want to take
bribes ourselves and if the voting
public knows how corrupt we are they're
not going to vote for us so for various
different reasons they think they're not
going to win a particularly clean
election so they enable this violence
and use these violent groups to help
them fill up their campaign coffers you
know maybe they don't care about the
violence they don't want that to happen
they just want the money so they're
gonna let it happen so they can get the
money
whatever the cause that violence starts
continue with a middle-class buy their
way out so they buy private security
they live in gated communities they buy
houses in nice parts of town you know
it's like anyone in any normal place
they try to do what they can to provide
for their kids and so so you see this
proliferation of private security
services in a lot of these places in
spanish-speaking Central America every
single country they outnumber a police
news private security and you see that
everywhere in Afghanistan Bangladesh
Pakistan so that's what the middle class
does so the violence falls on the poor
and the marginalized and that's kind of
the implicit deal with these countries
you know you don't kill the voters you
don't kill the middle class that only
happens by accident or if it's sending a
particular message to someone who's
getting nosy and it has to get a
journalist or something
the violence falls on the marginalized
what do they do well they can't turn to
the state because state has been
politicized so the second thing that
happens is the the leadership these
politicians politicize their police and
security services because they can't
have the police and security services
arresting the violent groups that
they've promised to give impunity to
that would break their promise so they
have to they have to make those groups
more political and it turns out when you
politicize your security services good
people don't want to stay in perhaps not
surprisingly morale just plummets for
people who really want to do their job
and what you see is a lot of violence if
you're if you're a good policeman in a
bad system like that that's letting off
bad guys what do you do some people turn
to violence and they say look I'm a
white hat I'm going to use extrajudicial
violence because I know that the the
judges aren't going to convict these
people and the prisons aren't going to
keep them so you start seeing these
death squads that start up just squad is
really why I don't want to bump into
like yeah that's true but you see you
see them proliferate and then and so
those death squads are often conceived
of themselves as white hats right
they're just going to target drug
dealers but you know first you kill the
drug dealers then you extort some money
from the drug dealers so as not to kill
them then pretty soon you're a policeman
running a criminal gang that's affecting
regular people and so that's what you
see is this kind of trajectory and
suddenly if you're a poor person who's
being targeted by the criminals
you also can't turn to the police
because for all you know they're working
together they frequently are and if you
call the police you're just as likely to
run into the person who's kidnapped your
brother that you're calling the police
about as as to be helped and so you
don't do that so what do you do well a
mafia comes in for insurgents come in
the Taliban in Afghanistan or gangs come
in and they say look we'll protect you
for a price or we'll protect you against
the other gangs or you see vigilante
groups start and and the vigilante
groups tend to be young men who want to
do the right thing at first
you give a lot of eighteen-year-olds
guns and a lot of license and pretty
quickly those groups all go downhill too
and so what happens is you get these
self-defense groups that become criminal
groups you get criminal groups that come
in and act as more illegitimate
protection and the state does and so you
see these things like in Colombia you
had people at Pablo Escobar's funeral
paulo Escobar's random Eddy in cartel he
killed hundreds and hundreds of regular
people he killed hundreds of police
officers he set off bombs at bookstores
for little kids I mean it's not a good
guy but he also built lots of low-income
housing and he built soccer fields for
people and he gave away a lot to charity
and at his funeral people said we're
going to go to his tomb the way we would
to a Saints to pray because he did so
much for the regular person right so you
get these Robin Hood criminals who pose
as Robin Hood and they give away charity
and you see them all over the world and
they're they're doing all these horrible
things but their persona is that they're
the good guys fighting a bad state and
they can lodge within these poor and
marginalized communities because the
state is even worse get into that but
you know it can get pretty bad yeah it
seems like it the the inequality and the
desire for people to have some degree of
protection and to feel like they're part
of the tribe again and included is
almost creating the equivalent of a
market like a niche in the market right
for some absolutely step in so we've
talked about the bad stuff how can we
fix it did you come up with any
solutions and if so what were the what
were the roots that you found that
seemed to be the most efficacious at
getting around these issues absolutely
so it was a positive book that was my
goal if I couldn't come up with
something good I was just gonna go to
Mexico City and open a cooking store
something I like I could do that there's
no reason to keep studying violence if
there was no way to solve it thank
goodness for my livelihood
and my normal life I did come up with a
very common pattern that you saw in all
these countries the first step was the
colonel's the criminals were to overstep
the criminals would bring too much
violence to the middle class
usually it was by accident usually it
was that criminal groups were fighting
amongst themselves and the violence just
spilled over or terrorist groups were
fighting for recruits and so they were
getting more and more elaborate in their
terrorist attacks but for whatever
reason the violence finally starts
hitting the middle class and then the
middle class had a choice they could
either vote for a more repressive state
and as Central America it's called
monitory
Ironfist policies in America they call
it three strikes and you're out
but it's basically give the state more
license to kill give the state more
license to lock people up for smaller
reasons and if they did that the
violence would get even worse and I talk
in the book about why those repressive
measures tend to backfire
the gangs meet each other in prison they
learn from each other they metastasized
behind bars because what more can you do
they're already arrested so they learn
how to run transnational networks and so
you end up with a much worse problem if
you throw a lot more young men in jail
really quickly yeah for all sorts of
reasons the other way that middle class
could do could go is to vote for a more
inclusive state a less unequal state and
that was the beginning of things going
well usually they needed kind of a
social movement to help them make that
choice because it's much easier to vote
for repression it makes a lot more sense
you know tough on crime and politicians
could claim to be tough on crime while
not changing the basic governing
structure that was holding up all this
violence so to fight for inclusion you
tended out a social movement that said
wait wait wait this governing order is
rotten it's corrupt it's violence
there's bad things happening in the book
I tell the story of the u.s. civil
rights movement and then I kind of show
how that parallels what happened in the
Republic of Georgia and Columbia and so
on but if you get a lot of people who
vote for a good politician who runs in
order to fight this violence then you
have a chance but the politician that
has to do a couple of things that are
really hard for one person to do and in
the book I found that sometimes one
politician could do all these three
things in India that that happened but
often it was politicians at different
levels of government because what they
had to do
was make dirty deals with the violent
groups because the state was so weak
that they can't just fight their way out
of the situation it's too weak to fight
because in Italy one of the reformist
mayor's for instance said I don't even
trust my secretary
I think the mobs infiltrated that far
and so you know how do you fight when
your whole state is rotten in Colombia
when they were trying to fight Pablo
Escobar the intelligence kept leaking
out of the police and right back to the
cartel so you know when you've got a
leaky situation like that so they need
to make deals where they give these
criminal groups some kind of
get-out-of-jail-free card
often a chance to make corruption from
jobs in the state in Georgia they put
the two big warlords into the state
actually give one the ministry of
defense and one the Ministry of Interior
so that they would stop killing each
other in the streets so something not so
pleasant number one but number two they
have to make the state more inclusive so
those things are absolutely at odds
right the state has to then help the
poor and care about the marginalized
people and make them feel part of the
same state really hard for the same
person to do that and then the third
thing they have to do is fight the
remaining criminal groups and violent
groups so you make it make a deal with
them get rid of as many as you can
through the deal create inclusivity
which gets you more intelligence and
gets you the poor people who had been
inadvertently or undesired you know they
didn't want to harbor these criminal
groups but they didn't have a choice
they start turning and they start
turning to the state and then you need
to fight if you can do those three
things and I saw that happen in a number
of places but often it was you know
Colombia the president made the dirty
deal and did the fighting the mayors
were the ones who were willing to build
a more inclusive state so fine together
it worked and together they made it
happen if you could do those two things
or three things then state would get
much much better and then people could
start self policing and really taking on
the role of making sure violence came
out of their society it wasn't
normalized anymore that's not an easy
task is it like we said at the very
beginning I just think that there's a
lot of serious conversation
that you probably are a part of like
that is to sit down with someone and go
right mate
congratulations you've become like king
of the hill for the time being first on
the agenda second on the agenda third on
the agenda like that guy is not going to
be a very happy or popular or haven't
he's definitely not gonna have good
sleep like for the rest of his tenure
he's not gonna be sleeping very well
well so one thing I found out about
these people who run for office on is it
first of all they don't sleep they're
like the Energizer Bunny
in fact in the Republic of Georgia
Saakashvili who's one of these reformer
types was known as the Energizer Bunny
that was his codename because he just
didn't sleep he had meetings at 12 he
had meetings at midnight he had means at
four in the morning he just all night
they're all like that they're all
hyperactive at first I thought it was
just an aberration but and also I should
say they're not really reformers they're
very interesting people the people who
look at a country like that yeah imagine
you look at a country that's basically a
failed state there's violence everywhere
there's corruption throughout the whole
system it looks like a complete basket
case and you say you know look at
Venezuela right now and you say I'm
gonna take over and make this place good
you know what kind of person thinks that
you can do that well it's a particular
kind of person is a very egotistical
kind of a person very high energy and
someone who really believes in
themselves a lot and you need those
characteristics so they're good
characteristics and that they need those
things to get through and to do these
incredibly tough tasks but they have a
dark side and so you see these reformers
start out on as reformers and then as
they start doing things that are more
and more gray and people start
challenging them they get upset and they
get more autocratic and they get more
authoritarian and they need to be thrown
out by the same population that voted
them in so you see this kind of loop of
reform they're causing and so it's
really important for outsiders to help
help the reformer at the beginning but
then recognize when that curve starts to
turn and not hold on to them too long
because if you if you keep thinking or
former when they become an autocrat
that's the story of an awful lot of the
independence fighters in a number of
African countries for instance yeah I
got that were there any really
surprising stories or any kind of
shocking moments while you're doing your
research you said that you traveled to
an awful lot of countries an awful lot
of interviews was there anything in
particular which that I mean it sounds
like there would have probably been
quite a lot of highlights on the
highlight reel but was there anything in
particular that stood out oh gosh so
many stories we could talk for another
half hour but there's one of them when I
was in Colombia I was trying to track
down this investigative journalist there
was an investigative journalist who went
by the name of nacho like the chips and
absolutely like the guy who had he knew
what had gone on inside the kaalia
cartel and the mid-eighteen cartel he
knew what was going on inside the
paramilitary groups he had been targeted
for assassination 22 times everything
everyone wanted to kill this guy because
he knew so much the Colombian military
tried to kill in their intelligence
services both the cartels the
paramilitaries just everyone had it in
for him and I wanted to know some of
what he knew because trying to figure
out the violence in Colombia is really
difficult it's a really complex
situation so we make appointments they
cancel the appointments and I'd make
another appointment you cancel and I was
getting ready to leave Bogota and I
really needed to meet with him and
finally made an appointment it is a
four-story walk-up apartment building
and I said okay I'll be there and he
kept that appointment so I go up to the
apartment building I walk up the four
floors I'm heavily pregnant I should add
at this time I was six months pregnant
when I was doing that part of the
research sign this bowling ball walking
up these four flights of stairs and get
to his little tiny apartment he locks
maybe five six padlocks on the door and
then he says my bodyguard didn't show up
today now in Colombia bodyguards were
given by the government because the
violence is so much that if you've been
targeted a lot you can request a
state-funded bodyguard it's not old old
tactic in Colombia that if The Bodyguard
doesn't show up that's when you're going
to be targeted next because the state
will withdraw the bodyguard and then
someone will parties they lost a number
of presidential candidates this way so
he says my bodyguard didn't show
and I'm thinking I'm sitting on your
couch six months pregnant you know right
but you know his teenage daughters in
the room by and and she's this lovely
beautiful teenage girl and I'm just
thinking well she doesn't seem scared
she's making a snack I guess I will you
know do this interview and so you know I
just sat watching the padlocks on the
door hoping that they held and we did
the interview and he gave me incredible
information that was really useful the
book and you know so far so good he's
made it through Wow easily in contact
with him I'm gonna guess he's a
difficult man to get hold of off and on
I you know had to ask him for permission
to use the language that I used in the
book and things like that so a little
bit that's cool that's really cool yeah
yeah well it's that those are the guys
that are in women who are really doing a
brave work you know this the kind of
violence inquiry that they do
that's why journalists are the Canaries
in a coal mine for all of this it's why
they keep getting killed all around the
world because they are really the ones
who expose what's going on in these
countries so they're a degree of
lifeblood I suppose so before we finish
I want you to ask most of the audience
will be from the UK but we are exposed
to the American politics with without
exaggeration probably almost as much as
we are to our our own especially in the
last few months we get the news it's as
newsworthy to hear Trump as it is dear
to resume which is I think a marker for
how kind of dramatized to a degree the
American political system has become
moving forward if you were if you were
writing an open letter to Donald Trump
and to his advisers what would you say
with regards to trying to improve these
inequalities and improve the way that
certain areas of the country are at the
moment that's interesting so first of
all I said your UK audience that all the
research was funded by different if it
is really trying to figure out how to
how to fight violence in better ways
because the taxpayers pays to pass a law
in your country that not 0.7 percent of
the money has to go to development aid
and
that money half goes to
conflict-affected States and violent
States and so they fund research like
this to figure out what do we do better
and so I'm in deep contact with it and I
feel very strongly that they do much
better work than they get credit for
really really good work what would I say
to our government I don't think I would
start with Trump to be honest I mean one
of the the findings of this research is
that if someone is complicit with
violent groups and wants to run this
kind of criminalized governing order you
can't make headway with that group
that's how they stay in power right how
does Trump stay in power he's staying in
power in part with a very nativist
audience in America they're not
necessarily violent but their interest
is in a nostalgic return to whites being
in charge of the country you know a
pre-1960 if you look at the 20% of the
voters that propelled Trump forward in
the Republican primaries so the other
half of my brain works on American
politics they do international work
after that so I think about this a lot
and if you break down the polls there
were about 20% of voters who weren't all
Republican I should add these were often
swing voters typical half Democrat half
Republican you know they vote for either
side who propels him in the primaries
after they they voted Republican for
that and they heavily heavily believe
that you can't be a real American if
you're not white if you're not Christian
if you're an immigrant you can't be a
real American you know those are not
common views in America but they're the
majority among his primary selectorate
in the electorate and as so that's who
he's campaigning to that's his basis you
would say and those people are not
wanting to change the inequality in fact
they want to turn it back so it wouldn't
go to them I would go to state-level
governments where you know in America we
have a federal system that's quite real
and there's a lot of states that have
leaders who do want to change things and
if you wanted to fight inequality
there's a couple of things you need to
do I think the first thing to recognize
is that political equality has to come
before and kind of with economic
equality it's not enough just to give
away money there's all this talk now
about a minimum wage a guaranteed
minimum wage
that's fine it's good to give poor
people you know some help but what you
see in places like Bihar India and
Columbia's people need to really be able
to vote they need to believe those votes
count they need to be able to change
power when they have the ability to
change power politicians have to cater
to them too and a democracy and so
ultimately that allows them to get the
economic help that they need to get the
jobs that they need even more than the
handouts you know it's things like that
so the inequality has to start from that
level of political power and in America
that has a lot to do with lobbying power
and you know who who gets the right to
get some time that all of that has a lot
to do with campaign finance in America
you know the rules that say that the
floodgates of money can open make
elections so expensive in America that
people think it's just pure corruption
you know just money for politics it's
not like that I worked for a decade
running a very political organization
and I didn't find almost anyone there's
a handful but almost anyone who's just
corrupt what you find is that they have
to campaign to campaign they need a lot
of money to make that money they need to
go speak at fundraisers with really
really rich people and so they spend a
huge amount of time with extremely rich
people even if they're people who care a
lot about equality and inequality
they're spending all their time with
really rich people so they can get the
money together to run the election so
the really rich people's ideas rub off
you know they can't help but rub off and
so even if you start off wanting to help
the poor you're thinking about it
through the eyes of a very rich person
has no idea what really would help the
poor and over time it becomes hard to
separate those things so it's the system
of money in itself it's not the
corruption per se I totally get that I'd
be absolutely fascinated to have you
back on so that we can discuss I feel
like we've got a really interesting
conversation that you could enlighten
some of our listeners about the
difference between the u.s. and the the
UK political systems and why those are
the case I've always been always been
fascinated to work it out so that that
may have to happen another time but I've
absolutely loved today Rachel thank you
very much for coming
I will make sure that a link to a savage
order your new book will be in the show
notes below where can the listeners find
you online and also if there's any other
resources if or videos or websites if
people are interested have you got any
way that you could recommend that they
could go sure so they can go to my
website Rachel Kleinfeld comm and then
they'll find yes the same name is on the
book and they'll find most things that I
do in most videos and so on and I can
also send you something set to link to
that would that would go directly to the
heart of the matter
fantastic that sounds awesome Rachel
it's it's been a blast if I can twist
your arm and if the audience want you
back so that we can talk about some UK
versus u.s. stuff that'd be cool if
that's the case make sure that you
comment below drop me a message on
Instagram or wherever else you are
listening but for now thank you very
much
[Music]
you